believe it or not I don't just net take
good movies so it's time for another
nitpick rant this one's going to be a
little different the last two of these I
did were on good movies and this time
I'm going to talk about Batman Forever
which is a movie most people do not
consider to be a good movie I know it's
not great I should think it's better
than a lot of people give it credit for
I think the aesthetic is a good balance
between the older gothic aesthetic that
Tim Burton brought before went
completely overboard with Batman or
Robin I think in a lot of ways how bad
Batman and Robin was which is
inexcusable getting you know died sort
of dragging down people's opinion a
Batman Forever which is not nearly as
bad Val Kilmer is fine he is not
exceptional Chris O'Donnell is actually
pretty darn good as Robin Jim Carrey is
just playing a stock Jim Carrey
character of the time as the RZA but
honestly I think is a perfectly valid
interpretation of the character Tommy
Lee Jones as two-face is wrong on so
many levels in terms of representing the
character but honestly because identify
these kind of fun but I'm not here to
defend this movie but I can watch it and
enjoy it
up until this one specific moment where
something happens that I just and I
can't I did okay so I'm going to paint
your picture here I'm going to describe
it to you and tell you what happens I'm
not going to use the clip because I
don't want this video flag and there
doesn't seem to be a lot of writing or
even of what does or doesn't apply we
use video clips but in any case so this
is the scene where Bruce Wayne has gone
to a party that Edward nygma is hosting
and then two-face crashes it to rob
people hoping to draw out Batman wakes
of course he does Batman crashes down
through the chandelier and fighting in
Sue's all this is you know you probably
remember bits of this there are a couple
decent lines it's that it's the scene
where Jim Carrey goes your entrance was
good is was better its vaccine now when
Batman crashes through the skylight and
as on his way down we get a shot
of dr. chase meridian played by either
cold Kidman sort of spinning around and
spotting him and in that same shot
there's this guy and this guy while
pointing up says and I quote Batman ah
that's it like exactly like that
I'm not messing with you I'm not
exaggerating I went back to check this
thing to make sure that my memory didn't
make it worse but no it is really that
Poindexter I don't know what over to
describe this in unbelievable dorky
Batman yeah I just what why why is that
bear by me first of all this is not the
first time the Batman has shown up in
the film what point is that no the first
time the Batman has shown up in front of
civilians so if they were going to have
a character have that kind of reaction
to him you know what I wouldn't love it
but I might have let it go if it was
like the guard at the beginning that
he's rescuing from to face you know the
guy with a hearing aid except he kind of
look dubis and it went back I said early
on Batman I like it that would be dumb
but I could move down from it where did
this guy come from and this isn't like a
case of an extra like worming his way
into just being right next and Nicole
Kidman
there was no way nobody noticed that he
was doing this actually - one of the
point that they have him to do this this
is that Joel Schumacher somebody told
him yeah go ahead and do that because
there's voice Batman ah come through so
clearly to me to like it has to have
been dumped in like this wasn't a gauge
of oh we missed that that Nate it's like
it's highlighted why why is this dorky
freakin like typical hammer shot it's a
cool hammer shot of your female lead
turning around and our hair goes behind
her is cheesy but it's classic huh it's
like almost a Marilyn Monroe mo would
imagine
and like when Marilyn Monroe stands on
the great and the wind goes up there's a
guy right next door going ha ha ha why
is it pointing out what's going on
everybody's looking everybody sees
everybody knows it isn't what boy this
boy this guy oh my god Joey why why is
he here whitey in the shot why are we
listening to this language and voice
just every time I hear it it just I can
feel like I'm having a stroke and that
is a thing in a movie that while not
good is otherwise enjoyable that just
really bugs the heck out of me when I
get that part so that's it for this knit
tick ranch so what what do you guys
think about this position one like I
said a little bit different from the
other ones I've done um anyone else
notice or remember that guy or was it
really just me who just couldn't stop
thinking about that whatever you thought
it's our job something down in the
comments let's talk about it don't
forget the like subscribe check me out
on twitter at council's geeks give a
listen to the council geeks podcast
available on itunes and stitcher and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]